(crew talking in background)
- [Crew Member] Step away from the door.
(door opens and closes)
- [Mark] All right, Kesha.
- [Kesha] Yeah.
- [Mark] Kesha, where'd you grow up?
Where are you from originally?
- [Kesha] Memphis, Tennessee.
- [Mark] Memphis.
And tell me about your childhood.
You had both your parents
when you were a kid?
- Well, I had my mom.
Dad was in and out.
My mom was a single
parent, seven children.
I'm the oldest.
I kinda played older sister mama.
Mom went to work.
- [Mark] Right.
- So I kinda, being the older person.
- [Mark] And how would you
describe your childhood?
- Well, I had a awesome childhood.
I wasn't wanting for anything.
Like I said, my mom was the mom and dad.
She took real good care of us.
It was seven of us.
I had a awesome childhood.
- [Mark] No abuse, no--
- No abuse. Well, I was molested,
by my step daddy, he molested
me when I was a child.
I tried to tell everyone, but
did not want to believe it.
- [Mark] Yeah, that happens a lot.
- Yeah. As time got older,
it finally came out.
I went to all type of crisis and classes
and here I am today.
- [Mark] So how far did you go in school?
- I graduated from 12th grade.
- [Mark] Good for you.
- South Side High.
- [Mark] And then,
where'd you go after that?
- Nowhere.
(Mark laughs)
I just started working
in the warehouse, a machine operator.
- [Mark] And what led you
into this line of work?
- Well because I'm a single parent myself,
I have two children.
Dad ran off on me, when
I first got pregnant.
- [Mark] You raise them on your own?
- So I'm raising two children on my own.
Doing the best of my ability.
And I'm just taking one day
at a time. I wanna work--
- [Mark] How long you been doing this?
- About 10 years now.
- [Mark] And you find this money is
easier to live with--
you support yourself better
- Well yeah,
because I'm a single parent.
Any type of way I can
try to make ends meet,
I go for it.
- [Mark] And you're
doing it without a pimp?
- Well, I had a pimp when I was 15.
Kinda took me out of town, left me.
I came back and did
never date a pimp again.
Took all my money, beat me,
just left me out there for dead.
I finally found my way
and been here ever since.
- [Mark] And how much
money would you make?
In a night?
- I would make $1000
but like I said he was
taking it and stealing it
and all I didn't make and
he was abusive.
All I didn't give it to him,
he would beat me real bad
for me to get it.
That means I'm out on the street.
Have to do any and everything.
- [Mark] That was as a 15 year old girl?
- At 15.
- [Mark] Yeah, but how old are you now?
- I'm 31.
- [Mark] 31. And how much do you make?
It's harder now right?
- It is. It's kinda hard now.
Cause I done kinda slowed down
and I'm kinda mature and like I said,
I'm raising children on my own.
So I'm just trying to set a good example.
- [Mark] And are drugs
a part of your life?
- Well, I done tried pills here and there,
did some C with it.
So now I smoke marijuana.
The pimp, when I was 15, he
tried to give me some bad drugs
but once I found out what it was,
I kinda weened myself off.
Went to a AA class and
haven't seen it again.
- [Mark] Good for you.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] You been arrested doing this?
- Yes I have. For assault,
defending myself.
But nothing major.
- [Mark] And the guys that pick you up
have you ever had hard times with them?
Bad experiences?
(sirens)
- Yes, sir. Some guys,
wanna pay you and then
they take the money back
so I had to fight my way
out of a lot of situations.
Try to stay alive.
Cause the guys will pay you,
then take the money back
truck drivers,
and leave you out there,
leaving me to find my way back.
- [Mark] Does this life
get you down sometimes?
- Sir...
- [Mark] Do you get depressed?
- I do.
Very often.
But I'm so thankful and grateful that
I'm here today and I have my life
due to, I've been through so much
and I was molested at a younger age so
and it was by my step dad so
- [Mark] Do you feel like that kind of
changed the course of your life?
- It did.
- [Mark] It did.
- I was going to class,
getting counseling,
trying to overcome that.
Cause like I said, a lot of
people didn't wanna believe
when I found it, when it got
older, finally came on out
that he was doing this.
- [Mark] Yeah, and does that affect
your relationships with
men now, as an adult?
- Well, some guys.
I just try to take it little easy.
Some guys, they come off a little harsh.
I try to do everything by the book now.
Yeah.
- [Mark] What's the hardest
part of this life for you?
- Well, trusting people.
Trusting people.
Cause when I was a child, like I said,
I was molested and going through so much,
people didn't believe me,
I just have trust issues.
- [Mark] Yeah, well it's
also the circle of people
that you're interacting
with on the street or...
The tricks, the pimps,
the cops, the other girls,
everybody is like looking
out for themselves.
- Right, everybody's
looking out for themself.
- [Mark] And you're just like it...
It's dog eat dog out there.
- Right.
- [Mark] It seems.
You carry a gun with you?
- Yeah, I have license to carry.
(Mark laughs)
- [Mark] I haven't met a person yet
in Memphis that doesn't.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] Everybody's
packing something here.
- Yeah. I'm licensed to carry.
- [Mark] I feel very vulnerable here.
(Kesha laughs)
I'm the only white person in this hood
and I'm the only one without a gun.
- Nah, y'all good people though.
- [Mark] I'm an idiot.
Do you recall the very
first time you did this?
- Back in 2000.
- [Mark] Tell me about that.
- Well I was with this photographer,
I don't know how it seems to be
he came off very nice.
- [Mark] Yeah, they do that.
- Then we got on it
(Mark laughs)
to behind closed door.
- [Mark] We do that, yeah.
- It's like a--
you let me give you the pussy
if I want you to have the pussy,
you know what I'm saying?
Don't just try to come up
and throw yourself onto me.
I'm like "hey I thought
I was here for one thing,
you really trying to fuck"
So I just try to be careful on those tips.
- [Mark] But that was for money?
- Yeah it was for money still,
but he didn't tell me,
he told me was like an eighth and thing
but then we got behind closed doors
"oh we got to do this, we got to do this"
just want so much.
- [Mark] You got to watch
those photographers.
- Yes
(Both laughing)
- [Mark] They're sleazy bastards.
- Yes.
And I mean it was a lot for me.
- [Crew Member] We're not all like that
- [Mark] They're not all like that.
- Yes, and I'm like "I
thought you was trying to
take picture of my body"
I was a exotic dancer
for many years as well.
- [Mark] Oh you were a stripper?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] And how is
working as a prostitute
different than working as a stripper?
- Well, it's a whole lot different,
because, us as women, we working
to the vibe of the clubs.
We can't sell pussy,
head, can't fuck tricks,
it's strictly dancing.
- [Mark] Yeah.
- I'm all for that.
- [Mark] A little more dignity
being a stripper than--
- I mean, people love seeing that ass so
(Both laughing)
I just get up there
and do what I go to do.
You know, my looks bring
me out anyways so--
- [Mark] Oh yeah, you're beautiful.
- Yeah, I stand there, guys be attracted.
So I don't have a problem with it.
Lot of times, I prefer to dance,
you know what I'm saying?
Shit, then fuck and suck all the time
(Both laughing)
- [Mark] Do you think you're addicted
to this life now?
- I'm not gonna lie, I am.
They seen so much money come through,
in and out.
- [Mark] I think everybody is.
If they say no, I don't buy it.
(Kesha laughs)
- Right.
- [Mark] I mean the temptation to
make that fast buck.
- C'mon now.
- [Mark] How are you gonna say no
I'm gonna go back to my
job at the grocery store.
- The job we gotta work
every week, every two weeks.
You know I may be
something I need in the...
- [Mark] Are you secretly
hoping that some prince charming
comes along and saves you from this?
- [Kesha] I am, I am.
I just hope, somebody
that is my husband comes
sweep me off my feet,
take care of my kids.
- [Mark] Make your life easier.
- [Kesha] Yes, make my life easier.
Won't have to struggle so hard.
Like I said, I'm a single parent,
I'm raising kids on my own.
Father been left us.
- [Mark] You've been in love before?
- [Kesha] Sir
- [Kesha] Yes, I have.
Heart got broke so many times,
I just throw it on out.
- [Mark] How do you think doing this
for a living has changed you?
- [Kesha] It has changed me tremendously.
It really has. It has
changed me tremendously.
I mean, in a good way, a very good way
because I was struggling with so much,
homeless, out on the
streets. From here and there,
there to here, with my children,
hotels, shelters, and I'm like
"you got to do something about it".
So I prefer, I get up all my food together
and my duty.
And get to making a way.
- [Mark] Does it build your self esteem
or does it tear it down?
- [Kesha] No it builds my self esteem.
- [Mark] It does.
- [Kesha] Yes, sir
- [Mark] Cause the guys worship you
and they pay you lots of money
- [Kesha] Yeah.
- [Mark] Come back
- You have regulars?
- [Kesha] Yes I do.
- [Mark] Yeah, I'm sure
- [Kesha] Yeah, I do.
- [Mark] What has this done for your...
like what you think of men?
- I mean--
- [Mark] Do you respect
men less because of this--
- I don't. Not all mens.
Because I done came a long way,
I've learned to forgive and forget.
I can't base my past off the future.
I have ran some good guys out
because I was so messed up
went through so much in my past
I done came around to try and
back socialize and talking
and open more up to guys
than I normally would have.
It was just a struggle for me,
I had to get something--
you know get it done myself.
- [Mark] Do you think if your childhood
was different, if you
hadn't been molested,
if your dad was in the
picture, if things like that
were different for you, your life would
look very different today?
- Yeah, I probably think
I would have did more,
been successful at more.
- [Mark] You probably would have...
Your self worth would have been higher
so you would never have considered maybe
this kind of work.
- Right. I would have
never been that, yeah.
Been able, in the
lifestyle, here and there.
All cross country.
- [Mark] You must at some point
stand back and look at your life
- Right
- and go man this is so crazy
- I do
- here I am going out
to work again.
- Here I am
- where you can get killed.
- Right.
- [Mark] You have kids
you're trying to raise
but you're out there risking your life.
- Right.
- [Mark] It's a nutty
way to go through life
- It is.
- [Mark] It's probably very stressful
- It was.
- [Mark] Was?
- It is.
(both laughing)
- [Mark] You're still doing it right?
- Yes, it is.
- [Mark] You're dressed
like you're still doing it.
- Yeah, it is.
- [Mark] What advice would you give to
a young girl who's considering doing this?
- Just stay focused,
don't trust everybody.
Have to use your brain, your own brain.
There gonna be guys out
there manipulate you
manipulate us in all form,
fashion, type of way.
We just got to stand this,
stand up for ourselves,
do what we supposed to do.
Even if it seem wrong, we have
to follow what's best for us.
I don't recommend for any young girl
cause I worry about my
daughters and nieces
and cousins, you know what I'm saying?
You come across a wrong guy
these guys crazy,
you could be out, have good intentions on
doing the right thing, but
soon things don't go their way
you get beat and that leads to death
and all type of things.
I done heard the same
plenty of young girls
kidnapped, so I just
didn't want young girls
to go through what I went through.
If I could try to set example
if anyone need me to talk
to them, I'll talk to them.
Don't go through what I went through.
Far as pimps, drugs, you
know what I'm saying?
No.
- [Mark] Tell me about, how
you met that first pimp?
When you were 15.
- He left me in a place
where I have no idea
I'm 15 years old, I'm still a child,
trying to be grown.
Smelling my tail, hanging with my cousins
Pimp came across me,
know I was selling pussy
so came and sweet talk me in my hear
I went for it
and then been hell living,
wouldn't something I
wish I would never did.
- [Mark] Do you think he
tricked you into that?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] He did.
- He did.
- [Mark] Like he was coming onto you like
he was a boyfriend?
- Right.
- [Mark] And then all of a sudden
- All of sudden, I got to pay you,
you beat me up, you wanna kill me,
if I don't give you my money.
So I done came a long way cause
I'm supposed to be dead
but I'm a living testimony.
but I am living testimony.
- [Mark] All right, Kesha,
thank you so much for sharing your story.
- You're welcome.
- [Mark] I wish you the best of luck
and good luck with your kids too.
- I sure appreciate it.
- [Mark] Thank you darling.
- You're welcome.
- [Crew Member] That was great.